EVERYONE KNOW THAT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB NINE SEVEN
EIGHT HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR.
NO OTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS AND WE'LL
START WITH FILE ITEM AIDS.
AB.
TEN FORTY NINE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON WHICH LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB TEN FORTY NINE WILL PROVIDE A
SALES TAX EXEMPTION FOR
EQUIPMENT PURCHASED BY
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEER FIRE
DEPARTMENTS.
VOLUNTEER FIRE DEPARTMENTS ARE A
CRUCIAL PART OF SERVING AND
PROTECTING THE STATE FROM THE
THREAT OF WILDFIRES.
IT'S MATTER FACT THEY COMPRISED
30% OF CALIFORNIA'S FIRE
DEPARTMENTS.
THERE ARE MOSTLY FOUNDED RULE
AND SMALLER COMMUNITIES AND AT
BEST THEY ARE ONLY MODESTLY
FUNDED.
THEY ARE EXPECTED TO CONTRIBUTE
THE SAME STAFF AND EQUIPMENT TO
FIGHT CALIFORNIA'S RAGING
WILDFIRES AS OTHER FULLY FUNDED
FIRE DEPARTMENT PROGRAMS.
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT ALLOW THE
SALES TAX EXEMPTION FOR
EQUIPMENT PURCHASED BY
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEER FIRE
DEPARTMENTS.
AB TEN FORTY NINE WILL PROVIDE A
SALES TAX EXEMPTION FOR
EQUIPMENT PURCHASED BY THESE
VOLUNTEER FIRE DEPARTMENTS.
AND IT WILL SAY THE IT WILL SAVE
THE VOLUNTEER FIRE DEPARTMENTS
ABOUT TWO MILLION STATEWIDE.
THIS NEW EQUIPMENT THAT WILL
REPLACE DECADES OLD MACHINES
WILL MAKE OUR CITIZENS SAFER AND
OUR FIREFIGHTERS MORE EFFECTIVE
MY WITNESSES WITH ME ALLOWED HIM
TO SELF INTRODUCED FROM CROCKETT
CARQUINEZ FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT.
BEFORE YOU DO WE HAVE A QUORUM --
CAN CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE HERE.
ROW [inaudible]
TO YOUR GRAY [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK HERE.
PREVIOUS TANG.
QUIRK WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
RICHARD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE THIS IS
A AN HONOR AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HELP A LOT OF PEOPLE.
IN THIS.
STATE.
MY NAME IS DEAN COLOMBO LINE THE
FIRE CHIEF FOR THE CROCKER
CARQUINEZ FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT.
I BECAME CHIEF IN SEPTEMBER OF
THIS YEAR WE'RE SMALL DISTRICT
WE COVER TEN SQUARE MILES WE
COVER THE COMMUNITY SUPPORT COST
A CROCK IN THE SMALL TOWN OF FOR
ME [inaudible]
THE BURDEN.
ON SMALL FIRE DEPARTMENTS.
HAS BECOME EXPONENTIALLY.
GREATER [inaudible]
IN YEARS.
WHEN I FIRST ENTERED THE FAR
SERVICE THIRTY SIX YEARS AGO
MUTUAL AID? TO YOUR NEIGHBORS
WAS AN EVENT THAT WAS FAIRLY
RARE.
NOW IT IS ALL THE TIME.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE THE
GREAT FIRES IN NINETEEN FIVE IN
LEXINGTON RESERVOIR FIRE OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE MUTUAL AID.
PROVIDED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HAS BECOME THE NORM.
AND THE LAST TWO YEARS.
JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT.
THESE FIRES ARE A VERY LARGE --
COMPONENT OF WHAT WE DO THE WEAR
AND TEAR ON OUR EQUIPMENT
[inaudible]
IS SUBSTANTIAL.
AND WE NEED HELP.
WE ARE CURRENTLY -- FOR EXAMPLE
MY DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY
PUTTING OUT TO BID FOR NEW
LADDER TRUCK FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
WE ARE REPLACING A TRUCK THAT
WAS PURCHASED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE IT IS WELL
BEYOND IT'S TIME BUT WE'VE HAD
TO HOLD ON TO IT. FOR THIS
AMOUNT OF TIME BECAUSE IT IS SO
EXPENSIVE.
WHEN WE DO PURCHASE THIS VEHICLE
IS GOING TO COST?
A LITTLE BIT GREATER THAN NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT.
THE FIRE ENGINE TO YOU SEE
TYPICALLY AT THE RESPONDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA WILDLAND FIRES A
LARGE TYPE THREES ARE
300-500-0024 HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A PIECE.
AT THAT AMOUNT THAT IS GREATER
THAN OUR ENTIRE BUDGET FOR A
YEAR.
WE'RE NOT ONLY TALKING ABOUT
WHAT WE DO AS FAR AS PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA FROM WILDLAND FIRES
BUT WE ARE SERVING OUR NEIGHBORS.
THE LITTLE TOWN OF CROCKETT IS
SURROUNDED BY DISTRICTS LIKE THE
CITY OF VALLEJO.
RODEO HERCULES FIRE DISTRICT
COUNT CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
CONSOLIDATED FIRE DISTRICT PANEL
CITY AND OTHER DISTRICTS OF HAD
TO CUT BACK.
AFTER THE RECESSION OF TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE WE HAVE FILLED
PART OF THE GAP FOR THEM AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO SO.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE ABOUT
VOLUNTEER DEPARTMENTS ABOUT
HELPING OUR NEIGHBORS WHEN OUR
NEIGHBORS CALL WHETHER IT'S THE
CITY OF VALLEJO OR ITS TRINITY
COUNTY WE ARE GOING TO BE THERE
WE'RE GOING TO DO WHATEVER WE
CAN TO HELP THEM.
WE'RE ASKING THE STATE TO HELP
US IN THAT.
IT'S NOT ONLY FIRE TRUCKS I'M
GOING TO HAVE TO REPLACE MUCH OF
THE AIR BOTTLES THAT WE CARRY ON
OUR BACKS ARE SELF CONTAINED
BREATHING APPARATUS.
BECAUSE THE REQUIREMENT IS AFTER
SO MANY YEARS THEY MUST BE
REPLACED THERE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A COPY.
AND I'M GONNA HAVE TO PLACE
BETWEEN THIRTY AND FORTY OF THEM.
THESE ARE MASSIVE EXPENSES.
WE ARE HELPING EACH OTHER WE ARE
A VITAL PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM AND I AND AND
TEXTING CITIZENS WE PROTECT
HIGHWAYS WE WE IN ARE WE
PROTECTING INTERSTATE.
EIGHTY A MAJOR CALIFORNIA
THOROUGHFARE THERE'S NO TAX
DOLLARS FROM THAT.
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO DO IT BECAUSE
WE'RE HELPING EACH OTHER AND
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT FOR US.
WANT TO CLOSE THE JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT HOW WHAT -- WHAT'S
HAPPENING -- IN THE NEWS THIS
PAST WEEKEND THERE WAS A REPORT
ON CBS RADIO.
REGARDING THE MULTIPLE VOLUNTEER
DEPARTMENTS IN CINEMA COUNTY.
THEY'RE HAVING TO CONSOLIDATE
RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE OF THE MASSIVE LOSS IN
TAX REVENUE BECAUSE OF THE NORTH
BAY FIRES.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT BUTTE
[inaudible]
TRINITY COUNTY.
LAKE COUNTY ARE GOING EXPERIENCE
VERY SIMILAR THINGS.
WE NEED YOUR HELP -- HELP THOSE
THAT ARE REACHING OUT AND
HELPING THEIR NEIGHBORS.
I THANK YOU AGAIN.
BENJAMIN PALMER ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY WERE THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU JUST AWARENESS IS IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BY THE COURT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION WE ACTUALLY DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL ON
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENTIAL NATURE.
I IT WOULD SET IN TERMS OF
SUBSIDIZING THE COST OF PUBLIC A
QUICK MEN IN THIS WAY THE SALES
AND USE TAX EXEMPTION --
CERTAINLY WE WOULD PREFER A
GENERAL UND ALLOCATION WE DO
CONSIDER THIS. TO BE A LOT OF
ALL PUBLIC POLICY GOAL WE'RE
JUST CONCERNED AGAIN ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT THAT IT SETS AT THIS
TIME WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION XENON COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR PARK.
SO YEAH THAT'S THE THE ISSUE
HERE IS YOU NEED THE MONEY.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
THE PROBLEM IS WHAT IS THE BEST
WAY TO DO IT -- I DON'T KNOW
MUCH ABOUT.
THESE -- DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE AND WHOSE WELL FUNDED AND
WHO ISN'T.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT.
YOU COULD END UP WITH A
RELATIVELY WELL OFF -- DISTRICT
GETTING A BIG BREAK AND THE
SMALL DISTRICT THE CAN CAN'T
REALLY EVEN PURCHASE EQUIPMENT
GETTING NO BREAK AT ALL.
AND THAT WOULD BE MY CONCERN
WITH THAT.
APPROACH AS OPPOSED TO A GRANT
REAP GRANT APPROACH -- SO THAT'S
THE OTHER WELL THERE'S ONE OTHER
ISSUE WHICH IS PROP NINETY EIGHT
DEPENDS UPON A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT COMES INTO THE STATE.
AND ONCE YOU DECREASE THE TAXES
COLLECT COLLECTED THOUGH YOU
DON'T MEAN TO CUT THE MONEY.
GOING TO THE SCHOOLS IN AFFECTED
CUTS THE MONEY GOING TO THE
SCHOOLS.
IF YOU HAVE A GRANT PROGRAM THAT
MONEY COMES OUT OF THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE GENERAL FUND.
SO THERE COUPLE OF REASONS THAT
A GRANT PROGRAM MIGHT BE A
BETTER PROGRAM THAN.
A SALES TAX.
REMITTANCE PROGRAM BOTH FOR
EDUCATION AND FOR MAKING SURE
THAT FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE GOING
TO SPEND A COUPLE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR -- WHERE DO YOU
SPEND IT WHERE IS THE BEST PLACE
AND WHAT IT SIMPLY -- TAX
MEASURE YOU MAY NOT BE SENDING
IT TO THE MOST NEEDY DISTRICT.
YES IF I MAY I'M NOT QUITE SURE
IF I HEARD A QUESTION IN THAT.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND OKAY --
IF I MADE MADAM CHAIR AND THE
FIRST THING -- ON THE SUGGESTION
OF A GRAND I RESPECTFULLY --
RECEIVE THE COMMENTS BY MY
COLLEAGUE -- MISSED WORK BUT ON
THE GRANT -- PROCESS A GREAT
SUGGESTION HOWEVER.
IN A GRANT PROCESS NORMALLY IT
COSTS AN ENTITY TO APPLY FOR A
GRANT -- NORMALLY THEY WOULD
HAVE TO HIRE ON A POSITION OR
REACH OUT TO SOMEONE THAT IS --
THAT DOES THAT IN A PROFESSIONAL
WAY TO EVEN HAVE A CHANCE TO
QUALIFY FOR A GRANT.
THEREFORE RISKING -- THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE PAYING OUT MONEY
TO BE A PART OF THIS GRANT
PROCESS.
AND MOST LIKELY WALKING AWAY
WITHOUT THE GRANT SO -- I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT AND RESPECT THAT --
HOWEVER IN A SALES TAX EXEMPTION
FOR VOLUNTEER FIRE DEPARTMENTS.
IT IT IS -- DESIGNED TO REACH
THE RULE -- AREAS MAINLY THAT
ARE UNDER SERVED I'M NOT SURE IF
WE WOULD FIND VERY MANY FIRE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE VOLUNTEER
AND SAN FRANCISCO OR LA FRESNO
OR SACRAMENTO -- IT'S MOSTLY IN
RURAL AREAS WHERE WILDFIRES ARE
HAPPENING.
SO -- THE TAX REVENUE THAT WOULD
BE LOST FROM THOSE WILD FIRES
ARE FAR GREATER THAN THE TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT -- THAT
WOULD BENEFIT VOLUNTEER FIRE
DEPARTMENTS.
PLACE YOUR BRO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- CHIEF
REAL QUICK IS HAVE YOU EXPLORED
THE OPPORTUNITIES OF MILITARY
SURPLUS EQUIPMENT MAY BE USED
EQUIPMENT FROM SOME OF THE
BIGGER.
ENTITIES IN THE STATE.
YES THE PROBLEM WE'RE FACING IS
THE FOLLOWING A LOT OF TIME A
LOT OF DEPARTMENTS.
PAID AND VOLUNTEER ARE
STRUGGLING SO MUCH THAT BY THE
TIME A PIECE OF EQUIPMENT IS PUT
UP FOR SURPLUS.
IT IS BEYOND IT'S TIME.
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE TRUCK THAT
WE'RE GOING TO PURCHASE.
BECAUSE OF THE CONSTRAINTS OF
THE SIZE OF THE COMMUNITY THE
SIZE OF OUR FIRE STATIONS SUCH
WE ARE REQUIRED TO GO OUT AND
GET SOMETHING THAT CAN FIT.
THAT IS NOT AVAILABLEON THE
OPEN USED MARKET -- SO THAT'S
WHY NOW WE ARE.
GOING TO BEYOND.
OUR OWN FUNDING.
WE'RE LOOKING OUT TO LOCAL
INDUSTRY WE'RE LOOKING OUT FOR A
BEER QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
AND REPLACEMENT FUNDS WE'RE
REACHING OUT AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
TO GET THE MONEY TO REPLACE
THESE EQUIPMENT AND IT'S JUST
NOT MOBILE EQUIPMENT.
I DID I TALKED ABOUT AIR PACKS
WERE TALKING ABOUT -- DEFEAT BE
LAY ALL THE THINGS THAT -- WE
ARE REQUIRED [inaudible] TO
REPLACE [inaudible]
UPDATE.
BASED ON STATUTE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW AND JUST OF STANDARD SUCH AS
NFPA.
SOUL THE THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
CONFRONTING AND MISTRESSES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SAT THING
REGARDING THE GRANTS I
APPRECIATE THE THE IDEA GRANTS
THE PROBLEM IS.
THAT A GRANT USUALLY AND WE ARE
REACHING OUT FOR GRANTS THROUGH
FEMA.
BUT THE PROBLEMS ARE THAT SO
MANY GRANTS ARE SO LIMITED --
NOT ONLY THAT BUT IT WE HAVE TO
BUY THESE THINGS.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF WELL IF WE
DON'T GET THE GRANT WE DON'T BUY
IT NO THOSE THEIR THEIR PACK
BALLS MUST BE REPLACED.
THE FIRE ENGINE MUST BE REPLACED --
AND THE THE OTHER THING WOULD
SAY THIS.
THE COST OF KEEPING OLD
APPARATUS.
IN SERVICE THE KERN APPARATUS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS
REPLACING WE CAN'T FIND PARTS
ANYMORE FOR IT THE COMPANY THAT
BUILT IT IS GONE.
AND IT SOLD SO THE COST OF
MACHINING THINGS AND SUCH IT'S
ASTRONOMICAL IT'S NICKEL AND
DIMING US TO DEATH [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUDGE I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
JUST JEFF YEAH YESTERDAY I
ATTENDED TO SPRING VALLEY
VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTERS PRACTICE
IN FUND RAISING YOUR BAND -- I I
SEE THE NEED -- FOR FOR THIS
BILL I ALSO ON TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK ALL THE
VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTERS TO ALL
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL GET AND CAN I ADD US --
COAUTHOR [inaudible]
Q..
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE -- I HAVE ONLY ONE
COMMENT WHICH IS THIS BILL RIGHT
NOW DOESN'T CONTAIN A SUNSET OR
IS NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
SECTION FORTY ONE SO WE WOULD
ACTUALLY TO WORK ON THOSE
MOMENTS -- AND WITH THAT THIS
ITEM IS FOR TESTIMONY ONLY BUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH MATT
OBJECT.
THANK MOVING THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB.
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I'D FIRST I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING ROSE MERRY
KINNEY FOR HER GREAT ANALYSIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AB EIGHT SEVEN TWO WILL HELP
CHILDREN ON SMALL FAMILY FARMS
STAY IN THEIR HOMES AFTER THE
DEATH OF A PARENT.
PARENT CHILD EXCLUSIONS
GENERALLY PREVENT PROPERTY TAX
REASSESSMENT FROM PROPERTY
CHANGES HANDS WITHIN THE FAMILY.
FROM PARENT TO CHILD.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
CONSISTENTLY SUPPORTED THESE
EXCLUSIONS BECAUSE THEY HELP
CHILDREN STAY IN THEIR FAMILY
HOME AFTER THE LOSS OF A PARENT.
DUE TO THE SMALL GAP IN OUR
COMPLICATED TAX LAWS NOT ALL
SMALL FAMILY FARM HOME STIFF ARE
PROVIDED A PARENT CHILD
EXCLUSION.
AB EIGHT SEVEN TWO ELIMINATES
THIS GAP IN THE LAW WHICH WILL
PROTECT SMALL FAMILY FARMERS AND
AGRICULTURE AGRICULTURAL OPEN
SPACE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
WROTE OUR STATE TREASURER FIONA
MALL IS SPONSORING THIS
LEGISLATION SHE DISCOVERED THIS
INEQUITY IN OUR TAX LAWS DURING
HER TIME AT THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION.
A REPRESENTATIVE CASEY O'CONNOR
IS HERE TODAY TO TALK TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
HI YES MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR SEEING US IN CASE
YOUR CAR LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR TREASURER FEE ON A MOCK WHEN
THE TREASURE WAS THE CHAIR OF
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN A CASE --
APPEARED BEFORE US AND WHICH
KIND OF BROUGHT THIS LOOPHOLE TO
OUR ATTENTION AS THESE ON THE
WOMAN NOTED THE CASE REVOLVED
AROUND A SMALL FAMILY FARM --
HOMESTEAD THOSE CONTINUOUSLY OWN
SINCE THE NINETEEN FIFTIES THAT
HAD BEEN REASSESSED FROM ITS
INITIAL WILLIAMS ACT PROP
THIRTEEN PROTECTIVE VALUE. TO
ITS MARKET VALUE WHEN THE OWNERS
DIED IN OWNERSHIP OF THE FARM
TRANSFER TO THE CHILDREN THE
REASSESSMENT LED TO A
SIGNIFICANT PROPERTY TAX
INCREASE WHICH THREATEN THE
CHILDREN'S ABILITY TO CONTINUE
LIVING IN THE FARM WHERE THEY
HAD BEEN THEIR WHOLE LIVES --
THE BOARD HAD SAID AT THAT TIME
THAT THEY BELIEVE THERE SHOULD
BE A BILL TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
THE BOARD HAS CHANGED OVER BUT
THE TREASURER HAD SAID THAT SHE
WANT TO SEE THIS TO PULL CLOSE
THAT'S WHY WE'RE BRINGING IT UP
NOW.
AND THIS BILL IS REALLY NARROW
IN SCOPE TO ADDRESS -- THE FOLKS
THAT WERE INCORPORATED AFTER
PROP THIRTEEN BUT BEFORE PROP
FIFTY EIGHT WAS IN PLACE AND SO
THAT'S WHY I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE TAKE CARE OF THOSE FOLKS
TO RESOLVE THIS INEQUITY AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR SUPPORT
WHEN IT COMES UP FOR ABOUT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL IN IS IS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS REGINA EVANS CHIEF
DEPUTY TO THE CURRENT BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION CHAIR MOLINA COME
WHEN.
MISS COLEMAN AGREES WITH THE
SPIRIT OF THE LEGISLATION AT
THIS TIME SHE'S NOT REGISTERING
A FORMAL POSITION BUT SHE
BELIEVES IT'S WORK WE SHOULD
SERIOUSLY TAKE A LOOK AT
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO THE RECENT
AMENDMENT.
OF THE BILL THE BOARD HAS NOT
BEEN ABLE TO FORMALLY TAKE A
POSITION BUT WE WILL DO SO PRIOR
TO THE ACTUAL VOTE ON THE BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL INTEREST IS IN
OPPOSITION TO COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS IN THE COMMITTEE.
I DON'T WORK.
I'M GREAT BILL.
THANK YOU I AGREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU -- FOR THIS IS FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR WHEN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OPEN
.
RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN I AUTHORED
LEGISLATION THAT ESTABLISH THE
ABLE ACT IN CALIFORNIA AND THIS
IS OUR ANNUAL CLEAN UP BILL TO
CONFORM WITH FEDERAL LAWS.
AB SEVEN THREE SIX WILL ALLOW
THE ROLL OVER A FUNDS FROM A
COLLEGE SAVINGS PLAN TO A CAL
ABLE ACCOUNT WITHOUT STATE TAX
PENALTY.
LAST YEAR CONGRESS PASSED
LEGISLATION THAT ALLOWS FOR
THESE TRANSFERS WITHOUT.
INCURRING A TAX LIABILITY AND
THE CHANGE IS NOT YET BEEN
REFLECTED IN CALIFORNIA THERE
FOR THIS BILL WILL.
ADDRESS THE DISCREPANCY.
AB SEVEN THREE SIX WILL CONTINUE
TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
CAN PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE BY
ALLOWING THE TRANSFER OF FUNDS
INTO AN ACCOUNT FOR MORE THAT
HAS MORE FLEXIBILITY.
WITH NEAR HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY
IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CAL A GOLD A CAL ABLE PROGRAM
DANTE ALAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DANTE ALLEN I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CAL ABLE.
I JOIN TREASURER MA -- THE CHAIR
OF THE CALLIE LACK BOARD IN
OFFERING AT THE ESSEX SUPPORT
FOR A BI.
SEVEN THREE SIX WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR WIN FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AS SHE HAS DONE SO MANY
TIMES.
AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CAL
ABLE I SPEAK REGULARLY WITH
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
WE'VE ALREADY MADE THE DECISION.
OR ARE CLOSE TO THE DECISION TO
OPEN IN KALIBO ACCOUNT -- THE
ABLE ACT HAS BEEN A LIFE
CHANGING EXPERIENCE FOR MANY OF
THESE PEOPLE THEY ARE VOCAL
ENERGETIC.
ABOUT THE WAYS TO IMPROVE THE
PROGRAM IN SUPPORT AS LONG TERM.
SUSTAINABILITY.
A LARGE PART OF THAT SUCCESS
WILL BE BASED ON OUR ABILITY
RETAIN THE TRUST OF THE MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACCEPTING CALIBER
FOR FINANCIAL. FOR THE FINANCIAL
INCLUSION OPPORTUNITY IF IT IS.
MANY OF THOSE EXPRESSING
INTEREST IN ABLE OUR FIRST TIME
SAVERS AND INVESTORS AND HAVE
PRECIOUS FEW RESOURCES TO LOSE
DUE TO A MISUNDERSTANDING OF NON
CONFORMING.
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS.
PARENTS WHO OPENED A COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNT FOR THE BENEFIT
OF A CHILD.
WHO NOW WANT TO ROLL IT OVER? TO
AN ABLE PLAN AFTER LEARNING THE
CHILD HAS A DISABILITY RUNS THE
RISK OF LOSING MONEY TO TAXES
AND PENALTIES SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY SEE.
THE MOST FLEXIBLE VEHICLE TO
INVEST AND SAVE FOR THEIR
CHILD'S FUTURE.
THE TRUST LEVEL OF THIS
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN LOW.
AFTER ALL YOU HAVE TO IMAGINE
THAT THEY'VE BEEN TOLD FOR
DECADES -- NEVER TO SAVE MONEY
AND THE NAME OF THE PERSON WITH
THE DISABILITY.
AND THEY'VE BEEN GIVING
CONFLICTING INFORMATION BY THE
AGENCIES THAT.
THE ABLE ACT WAS INTENDED TO
PROTECT.
AS OF FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
TWENTY NINETEEN THERE FORTY
THREE PROGRAMS IN OPERATION
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE MAJORITY OF WHICH ALLOW
PARTICIPATION BY NON RESIDENTS.
CURRENTLY SEVERAL EIGHT ABLE
PROGRAMS EXIST IN STATES WHERE
CONFORMITY WITH THIS TAX
PROVISION HAS ALREADY BEEN
ACHIEVED.
THE CALIFORNIA ABLE PROGRAM
LAUNCHED ON DECEMBER.
EIGHTEENTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT BEGAN
COMPETING WITH THESE OTHER
STATES PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
OUT IN OPERATION FOR OVER TWO
YEARS.
AND HAVE MARKETED TO ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS.
THEREFORE IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE MAXIMIZE INCENTIVES THAT
INCREASED CALLIE WAS
PARTICIPATION AND ULTIMATELY AS
LONG TERM VIABILITY IN SUCCESS.
THAT INCLUDES ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S NOT BE SUBJECTED TO
TAXES AND PENALTIES THAT OTHER
PROGRAMS HAD MANAGED TO AVOID.
SINCE DECEMBER -- SINCE OUR
DECEMBER LAUNCH.
WE HAVE BEEN MET WITH WIDESPREAD
SUCCESS.
AS OF THIS MORNING NINE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SIX ACCOUNTS HAVE
BEEN OPENS -- WITH OVER THREE
POINTONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ASSETS UNDER MANAGEMENT.
WE BELIEVE THAT AB -- SEVEN
THREE SIX IN ADDITION TO
ELIMINATING THE TAXES AND
PENALTIES DUE TO A ROLL OVER
FROM A COLLEGE SAVINGS PROGRAM
WILL INCREASE THE NUMBER.
OF INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS WHO ELECT
TO OPEN -- ABLE COUNTS WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL FURTHER
PROMOTE CONSISTENT SAVINGS FOR
BEHAVIOR AMONG CALIFORNIA'S WITH
DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU FIRST CONSIDERATION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR FAST
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES HERE YOU JUST COME
TO THE TABLE.
I'M SURE MEMBERS TO ME FROM IN
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FOR IT THE PROMPT SPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE.
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE THAT QUIRK --
I LIKE THIS.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN TRANSFER --
YOUR RETIREMENT SAVINGS.
FROM ONE RETIREMENT ACCOUNT TO
ANOTHER WITHOUT PAYING THE TAXES
I THINK THIS IS COMPARABLE I
THINK IT MAKES SENSE I'M GLAD
YOU BROUGHT IT FORWARD.
HIGH PRAISE FROM DOCTOR QUIRK IT
REALLY IS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THEM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
JUST -- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU DESIGNS FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY THANK YOU.
ARE YOU HAVE A FILE ITEM.
NUMBER FIVE AB.
EIGHTY FIVE OF AB HAD EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE WILL HELP THE VICTIMSOF THE CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET BY PROVIDING
MUCH NEEDED PROPERTY TAX RELIEF.
THOMAS FIRE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
RESULTED IN THIRTEEN HUNDRED
STRUCTURES DESTROYED OR DAMAGED
IT WAS THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE IN
STATE HISTORY UNTIL. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I WAS -- SEVENTEEN WHEN
THE MENDOCINO COMPLEX CAMPAñA
BUTTE AND WILLS HE FIRED
DECIMATED THOUSANDS OF MORE
HOMES AND BUSINESSES.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS A TRANSFER OF
ONE'S PROPERTY TAX LIABILITY
FROM THE DESTROYED PROPERTY TO
SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE COUNTY SO
A VICTIMS PROPERTY TAXES DO NOT
SPIKE.
CURRENT LAW ALSO PROVIDES AT THE
NEW PROPERTY WILL BE UP TO A
HUNDRED AND 20%.
OF THE VALUE A CAN BE UP TO A
HUNDRED AND 20% OF THE VALUE OF
THE DESTROYED PROPERTY.
PROVIDING A SMALL SAFE HARBOR
FOR IMPROVEMENTS ABOVE THE
ORIGINAL VALUE WITHOUT
TRIGGERING A REASSESSMENT.
THE SAME STANDARD OF A HUNDRED
AND 20% DOES NOT EXIST FOR
PROPERTY OWNERS WHO WISH TO
REBUILD ON THEIR CURRENT SITE.
AB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE CORRECT SAID
IN EQUITY AND CURRENT LAW BY
DEFINING SUBSTANTIALLY
EQUIVALENT. TO PROVIDE THE SAME
HUNDRED AND 20% STANDARD OF SIZE
OR VALUE FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
REBUILD ON THE SAME PLOT OF LAND.
ON THAT THAT THE DESTROYED
PROPERTY STOOD ON THEIR SIMILAR
PROVISIONS FOR THOSE WHO LOSE
PROPERTY DUE TO EMINENT DOMAIN
OR ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINATION.
BY CREATING CONFORMITY WITH
OTHER AREAS OF PROPERTY TAX LAW
AB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE WILL HELP
SUPPORT THOSE WHO HAVE LOST
EVERYTHING AND ARE STRUGGLING TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSESSORS ASSOCIATION I'M ROB
GROWS CLOSER -- AND MUCH MY WEST
MAY I WAS NOT BLESSED WITH A
SHORT LAST NAME LIKE YOUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT FOR MY SWISS
RELATIVES -- BUT I WANT TO THINK
THE SALOON FOR BRINGING FORWARD
AB -- EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THIS
RESULTED FROM OUR ASSOCIATION
COMING TOGETHER THIS PAST FALL
AND HAVING A COMBAT THE
DISCUSSION ON DISASTER --
DISASTERS IN THE STATE AND HOW
TO ASSESS THEM AND WE NOTICES
INEQUITY WHERE IF YOUR HOME IS.
DESTROYED YOU CAN MOVE ACROSS
THE STREET THERE'S A STANDING ON
PURCHASE IT UP TO THE WANTED 20%
VALUE.
BUT IF YOU ACTUALLY TO REBUILD
ON THE PLOT OF LAND YOU DON'T
HAVE THAT.
FLEXIBILITY SO TO SPEAK EVEN GO
OUTSIDE THE COUNTY TWO HUNDRED
FIVE HUNDRED TEN AND 5015% AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW EXITING YOUR
ACTUAL COMMUNITY THERE -- SO
LIKE TEN THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER NEXT ANALYSIS
I DO AGREE WITH THAT THAT THIS
IS ABOUT RESTORING THE PROPERTY
TAX HAS ACTUAL LEVEL THIS IS NOT
DECREASING IN.
A PLOT OF LAND COULD SAY VACANT
AND THEY'VE VALUES WOULD BE DOWN
WHICH WOULD BE HURTING LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ALREADY WITH THAT
LOST PROPERTY TAX BASE.
SO WITH THAT WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL IN THIS IS
IN SUPPORT.
A JUST COME TO THE TABLE.
THERE ARE CARL TO THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS AND ME DOCTOR QUIRK --
SO JUST READING THE ANALYSIS IT
SAID PROP EIGHT ESTABLISHED A
NEW CONSTRUCTION EXCLUSION
RELATED TO POST DISASTER
RECONSTRUCTION.
SPECIFICALLY REAL PROPERTY THESE
RECONSTRUCTED AFTER DISASTERS
CLEARED BY THE GOVERNOR WILL NOT
BE ASSESSED AS NEW CONSTRUCTION.
IF THE FAIR MARKET VALUE THE
READ.
REAL PROPERTY.
AS RECONSTRUCTED IS COMPARABLE
SO THERE IS.
A AND PERHAPS THE ASSESSOR CAN
ANSWER THIS THERE IS SOME
PROVISION IN LAW THE PROBLEM IS
THAT.
COMPARABLE REALLY ISN'T DEFINED
AND NOW YOU'RE DEFINING THAT.
AND THAT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO
ME SO I THINK THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THE BILL IS DOING.
YOU ALREADY HAVE SOME EXCLUSION
IT'S JUST HARD TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THAT EXCLUSION IS.
SO OKAY GOOD [inaudible]
THANKS ROGER.
SO INTENTIONALLY BRING HIS BILL
FOR ALL THE SUPPORT AND WHEN WE
VOTE ON IT -- IT'S A NO BRAINER
BUT I I THINK FOR THE ASSESSORS
WHICH WE SHOULD GO A LITTLE
FARTHER BECAUSE I'LL GIVE YOU MY
OWN EXPERIENCE.
I BOUGHT A HOME IN DANA POINT
THAT WAS CONSTRUCTED IN NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE IT NEEDED TO BE.
FIXED UP -- I DIDN'T AB ONE
SQUARE INCH DIDN'T FIX TOUCH THE
ROOF DIDN'T TOUCH THE YARDS BUT
I YOU KNOW PUT NEW RECEPTACLES
ARE IN THERE BUT THE BUILDING IF
ISSUE.
ADDED HE SAID ALL YOUR COMPUTER
WORKS CAN BE TWO OR FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT WAS ALL
SUBJECTIVE BUT THEN A CC THE
ASSESSOR.
AND I THINK I'M DOING A QUARTER
OF A MILLION DOLLAR REMODEL
WHICH I'M NOT AND IT GOES ON THE
PROPERTY TAXES.
AND THEN SO SO THAT'S ONE ISSUE
I THINK JUST IF YOU'RE FIXING UP
AT ALL PLACE.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN ARGUE IF A NEW
LIGHT SWITCH IN A NEW RECESS
OUTLET IS.
VALUE TO YOUR PROPERTY -- THE
OTHER ISSUE THAT YOU SHOULD LOOK
AT TWO IS THAT.
IF THE ASSESSORS THIS HAPPENED
WITH MY PROPERTY IF YOU'RE OVER
ASSESSING THE VALUE BASED ON A
CONSTRUCTION -- AND THEN WHEN IT
SELLS THERE'S NO.
THERE'S NO RIGHT TO GET ANY OF
THAT MONEY BACK SO OUR PROPERTY
IS BEING OVER SAYS BASED ON THIS
CONSTRUCTION THOUGHT.
THAT WE WERE DOING A TO A FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR REMODEL FOR ONE
AND IN FACT IT WASN'T THE CASE
AND WHEN WE SOLD IT YOU KNOW IT
WAS.
SOLD AT A DIFFERENT AMOUNT SO
JUST A COUPLE THINGS FOR YOU
GUYS TO CONSIDER MAKE ISRAEL
TAKE THE BACK TO CESSATION
SHOULD.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I THANK YOU FOR ADDRESSING THIS
INEQUITY OBVIOUSLY IT IS MOSTLY
ABOUT A DEFINITION AND SO THANK
YOU WHEN THE TIME COMES WE WILL
VOTE ON IT.
THIS FOR TESTIMONY ONLY NOW
THANK YOU THINK ABOUT CHAIR FOR
THE MEMBERS [inaudible]
I REQUEST LIVING A FILE ITEM SIX
AB NINE THIRTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REAVIS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
COLLEAGUES AND OR ARE COMMITTEE
STAFF.
WHILE AUTOMAKERS ARE TAKING
STEPS TO INCREASE THE PRODUCTION
OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
VEHICLES OF ALL SIZES.
OUR STATE MUST DO MORE IN THE
DEPLOYMENT OF ELECT OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE CONSUMER INCENTIVES IF
WE ARE TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS
IN THE STATE.
AB NINE THREE EIGHT INCENTIVIZE
IS OWNERS OF OLDER GAS POWERED
CARS. TO TRADE IN THEIR VEHICLE
AND PURCHASE A NEW OR USED
QUALIFYING LOW OR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE.
THIS BILL WOULD ENACT A NEW TAX
EXPENDITURE PROGRAM IN THE FORM
OF A PARTIAL SALES AND USE TAX
EXEMPTION FOR QUALIFIED MOTOR
VEHICLES -- AND FOR PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL THE QUALIFY MORE --
THE THE QUALIFIED OF MOTOR
VEHICLE AS ANY VEHICLE THAT
MEETS LOW ULTRA LOW OR ZERO
EMISSION STANDARDS SET BY
FEDERAL GUIDELINES -- THIS BILL --
IT DEFINES TRADE IN VEHICLE AS A
VEHICLE THAT IS ELEVEN MODEL
YEARS OLD OR OLDER.
AND IF WE TARGET OLDER OFTEN
LESS EFFICIENT VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD AND POTENTIALLY ENCOURAGING
OWNERS OF SUCH VEHICLES TO
PURCHASE LOW OR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES THIS PROGRAM.
COULD PLAY A ROLE IN HELPING OUR
STATE REACH OUR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE TARGETS -- AND FINALLY
ONE OF THE BIGGEST DRIVERS OF
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE INCENTIVES
HAS BEEN THE FEDERAL TAX CREDIT.
UNFORTUNATELY WITH RECENT
STATEMENTS MADE BY OUR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS OF CONGRESS THIS
FEDERAL INCENTIVE.
IS IN REAL JEOPARDY OF BEING
EXCLUDED IN THE NEW BUDGET
PROPOSAL -- AND SO WITH THAT --
I I HAVE HERE CLIFF CARDOZA WHO
WILL PROVIDE SOME TESTIMONY IS
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE NEW CAR -- THE
DEALER ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CLUB
COSTA WITH THE CALIFORNIA NEW
CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION TOTALLY
BUT NO NO WORRIES NO WORRIES --
THIS COMMITTEE HAS HEARD THIS
BILL IN VARIOUS FORMATS OVER THE
YEARS IN FACT THE STEAM CHAIR
HAD A BILL SIMILAR BILL TWO
YEARS AGO.
BUT THE REASONS FOR THE BILL
HAVE CHANGED A LOT ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR THAT IS IS WHAT.
THE AUTHOR JUST MENTIONED THE
FEDERAL TAX FEDERAL TAX CREDIT
OF SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
IS IN REAL JEOPARDY NOW.
THE PRESIDENT HAS PROPOSED TO
ELIMINATE THIS.
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT.
THE SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
IS THE BIGGEST PUSH.
WHAT HAPPENS BUT NOT OVER 90% OF
ZERO NEWS ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
ARE LEAST?
THE LEASING COMPANIES WHICH
TYPICALLY -- ARE SO SEATED WITH
THE AUTO MANUFACTURERS TAKE THE
TAX CREDIT FOR THE CUSTOMER AND
REDUCES THE LEASE.
PAYMENTS.
THE CUSTOMER HAS TO PAY ANOTHER
WORDS IT IS ON THE HOOD TIGHT.
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD ALLOW
CUSTOMERS TO PAY LESS EVERY
SINGLE MONTH.
YES THE STATE HAS THE CV OUR P.
PROGRAM IT IS AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM THE C. V. R. P. IS
RUNNING OUT OF MONEY EVERY
SINGLE YEAR.
AND EVERY YEAR WE KEEP REDUCE
SEEN OUR LEAST TALKING ABOUT
REDUCING THE INCOME CAPS.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE.
POOR PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING MY MOTHER.
WOULDN'T HAVE NEVER BEEN ABLE TO
PURCHASE A NEW ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE NO MATTER HOW MUCH MONEY
WE WOULD GIVE HER.
THIS BILL FOCUSES NOT JUST ON
NEW ZAPS BUT ALSO AND USE UPS
WHERE THERE ARE NOT A LOT OF
INCENTIVES AT ALL TO GET INTO
USED ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES.
I RECENTLY JUST PURCHASED A USED
A FIAT FIVE HUNDRED E. GOES
NINETY MILES IT IS MY COMMUTER
CAR BACK AND FORTH TAKES ME TO
MY MOTHER IN LAW'S TAKES ME TO
MY FAMILY.
THAT CAR WAS PURCHASED FOR EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IT'S THREE YEARS ALL HAD TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND MILES ON IT.
THAT IS THE TYPE OF CAR WERE
SOMEBODY COULD TRADE IN THEIR
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD VEHICLE AND GET
SOMETHING CLEANER.
IT IS IMPROVING THE FLEET IT IS
AN IMPORTANT ASPECT IN THESE ARE.
HONEST TO GOODNESS REAL
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS.
I KNOW THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN A
LOT OF TIME ON GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU IT IS
SOMETHING MY FOLKS ARE FOCUSED
ON WE WANT TO HELP SELL MORE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES THE WAY
TO DO THAT IS TO INCREASE
CONSUMER DEMAND.
THIS BILL WILL HELP CREATE
INCREASED CONSUMER DEMAND. ONE
FINAL THING I WANT TO SAY BEFORE --
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE BUT WHEN IT
DOES COME UP.
IF IT DOES COME UP -- IS
RECENTLY A STUDY WAS.
PRODUCED AND THERE ARE TWO AREAS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE KNOWN FOR HAVING THE OLDEST
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD.
THOSE TWO PLACES ARE THE SAN
FRANCISCO SAN JOSE BAY AREA.
AND EAST BANK.
IN SAN DIEGO.
SO OF THE TOP TEN PLACES IN THE
COUNTRY PEOPLE ARE KEEPING THEIR
CARS THE LONGEST HERE AND WE ALL
KNOW THE MOST POLLUTING VEHICLES
ON THE ROAD OUR OLDER VEHICLES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL IN THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
HEY WE GOT THE MIKE SET UP THEIR
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE
BRANDING RC ON BEHALF OF VALLEY
CLEAR DOWN TRANSPORT THIS
MEASURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON WE APPARENTLY ON
BEHALF OF TESLA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL WOULD
ENCOURAGE CONSUMERS TO PURCHASE
OF VEHICLES.
MADE BY CALIFORNIA'S ONLY AUTO
MANUFACTURER THANKS -- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE LIKE A COUPLE
OTHER BILLS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY DO NOT OF A
POSITION YEAH IT'S MADE THE
CORPSMAN AT COMPANY TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION THIS IS ACTUALLY ONE
OF TWO BILLS UP BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE RELATED TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES -- TODAY WOULD
NOT HAD A CHANCE TO COMMUNICATE
WITH EITHER AUTHORS OFFICE BUT
AS A MATTER OF PUBLIC POLICY CTO
RATE IS NOT OPPOSE INCENTIVIZING --
THE PURCHASE OF WERE YOU SAID
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE CERTAINLY
WE HAVE A PRETTY AMBITIOUS GOAL
TO MEET AS A STATE BY TWENTY
THIRTY ON WHERE WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ON THIS BILL ARE TWO
FOLD -- ONE AND THERE'S A LARGER
CONVERSATION HAPPENING OR WE
HOPE WILL BE HAPPENING RECORDING
FEDERAL TAX CONFORMITY WHERE THE
STATE SHOULD AND SHOULD NOT
CONFORM OBVIOUSLY THIS
POTENTIALLY COULD BE SOMETHING
THAT IS OUT OF CONFORMITY -- IN
THE STATE'S TAX CODE AND THE
NUMBER -- TWO AND THIS IS THE
LARGER ISSUE IS THE USE OF THE
GENERAL FUND TO SUBSIDIZE --
THIS TYPE OF INCENTIVE RATHER
THAN FOR EXAMPLE THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS IN
ALLOCATING DIRECTLY THROUGH
THERE AS PART OF A LARGER
TRANSPORTATION STRATEGY SO
BETWEEN NOW AND A POTENTIAL VOTE
ON THIS WOULD LIKE TO ENGAGE
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE ON NOT
SPECIFICALLY THANK YOU.
COMES THE QUESTION FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
SO MY I HAVE A COUPLE CONCERNS.
NOW THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO THINK
ABOUT THE FIRST ONE IS THIS IS
REALLY COMPLICATED.
SOMEBODY ISN'T GOING TO KNOW
WHEN THEY SAY I MEAN.
NOW AFTER BATTLE LEVIN YEARS
THAT'S ABOUT WHEN I TRADE MY CAR
AND I HAVE NO IDEA AT THE TIME
WHAT THE TRADE IN VALUE WAS
GONNA -- AND SO I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT I'M GOING TO GET BACK.
THROUGH THIS TAX BREAK OR EVEN
WHAT I'M GOING TO GET FOR THE
CAR.
SO I DON'T THINK THIS WILL
ACTUALLY ACT AS AN INCENTIVE I
THINK A BETTER INCENTIVE IS. FOR
EXAMPLE IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
THERE WAS AN INCENTIVE FOR
PEOPLE TO GET RID OF THEIR
CLUNKERS THERE WAS SO MUCH I
DON'T REMEMBER THE DETAILS.
BUT SO MUCH FOR CLUNKER OR WE
CAN JUST MAKE SURE THAT.
FRANKLY I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
TO HAVE INCENTIVES.
ARE FOR PURCHASE OF SECONDHAND
ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO KEEP THEM
ON THE ROAD.
OUR BUT AGAIN YOU COULD HAVE A
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS
OR ANOTHER FIND.
THAT SIMPLY MORE TRANSPARENT
THAN THIS MY DIFFICULTY IS THAT
THIS JUST ISN'T VERY TRANSPARENT.
THE PEOPLE WOULD HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT IT'S WORTH UNTIL
PRACTICALLY THEY BOUGHT THE CAR.
BECAUSE USUALLY DON'T EVEN FIND
OUT ABOUT WHAT YOUR TRADING IS
RIGHT AWAY YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
BLUE BOOK BUT WHO KNOWS WHICH
GAP.
SO IT'S THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
AND I JUST THINK OTHER TYPES OF
MORE DIRECT INCENTIVES MIGHT
WORK BETTER AND PERHAPS YOU
COULD PICK ABOUT THAT.
IT WAS A GREAT COMMENTS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SO I'M ACTUALLY ALSO PRESENTING
THE OTHER BELL ON ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES TODAY I'M JUST A
QUESTION IN YOUR PRESENTATION
YOU SAID THAT IT WAS LOW AND
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES SO WHAT
ACTUALLY IS WHAT IS A LOW
EMISSION VEHICLE.
SO I'LL DEFER TO QUIT.
YEAH THESE ARE BOTH VEHICLES
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE TO GET THE H.
APPEALING STICKER SO WELL LOW
EMISSION IS YOUR PLUG IN HYBRID.
THE MOST -- COMMONLY KNOWN AS
THE CHEVY VOLT BUT THE PREVIOUS
PRIME THAT AND OKAY RIGHT I JUST
WANT.
TO MAKE SURE THANKS.
I'M. TO DOCTOR COURTS POINT
THERE ARE PROGRAMS THAT ARE THAT
ARE LIKE OUR CLASS CASH FOR
CLUNKERS THAT DO TRIED
INCENTIVIZE FOLKS TO GET INTO
SECOND.
HAND THE VEHICLES HOWEVER THE
LINE FOR THEM IS THE WAITING
LIST FOR THEM IS SO LONG.
THAT -- WE WE DO HAVE A BACKLOG
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET.
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY AND TWO
ZERO MISSION AND LOW AND LOW
EMISSION VEHICLES AND SPECIALLY
THEY WILL ONLY AFFORD SECONDHAND
VEHICLES -- SO I CONTINUE TO BE
A SUPPORTER OF THAT CONCEPT I
BELIEVE THAT WE WILL NOT SEE POR
EL THE INTO ALL COMMUNITIES CAN
PARTICIPATE AND WE HAVE NOT
REACHED THAT POINT YET.
OUT WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YEAH YOU KNOW ALL I HAVE TO SAY
IS -- YOU KNOW IT'S GREAT TO BE
HERE -- AND THANK YOU LOOK FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF
TO MAKE SURE TO ACCEPT YOU KNOW
ANY AND ALL AMENDMENTS AND
HOPEFULLY WILL BE BACK IN AND AT
THAT TIME WILL -- YOU KNOW
RESPECT ASPIRIN AIBO THANK YOU
THANK MEMBERS.
LIVING FILE ITEM TO AB
.
SEVEN FORTY FIVE HI I WOULD LIKE
TO OPEN.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RECESSES WALL FOR SETTING
THE STAGE.
FOR ANOTHER BELL ON ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES SO I'M HERE TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE AND
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS ALSO
TO ENCOURAGE THE ADOPTION OF
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES.
AND THIS BILL IS SUBSTANTIVELY
REINTRODUCTION OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LAURA FRIEDMAN AB THREE
THOUSAND WHICH WAS UNANIMOUSLY
PASSED BY THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LAST SESSION.
I'M TODAY AS WE SAID THERE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
ON OUR ROADS IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN GOVERNOR BROWN
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
CALLING FOR FIVE MILLION ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA
BY TWENTY THIRTY SO WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO.
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES LIKE
THEIR PLUG IN BATTERY
COUNTERPARTS -- ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES THAT ARE POWERED BY
HYDROGEN CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
THE LARGEST HYDROGEN PRODUCING
STATES AND ITS HYDROGEN FUEL
CELLS ARE SUBJECT TO THE SALES
AND USE TAX.
SO DESPITE CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT IS THAT FUTURE
CONSUMER ADOPTION AS WE'VE HEARD
DOES REMAIN A CHALLENGE.
THIS BILL WILL CREATE PARITY
BETWEEN THE TWO SEVEN
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE IN THE
MARKET PLACE TODAY PLUGIN
BATTERIES AT EUROVISION VEHICLES
AND HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES.
THE PROPOSED EXEMPTION IS
TEMPORARY AND THIS WILL ENABLE
US TO EVALUATE THE EFFICACY OF
THIS POLICY CHANGE.
ON THANK YOU COMMITTEE FOR THE
ANALYSIS AND I THINK FOR YOUR
SUGGESTION ON A COUPLE POINTS OF
CLARIFICATION THERE IS A
QUESTION AROUND.
WHERE THIS WOULD APPLY AND IT
WOULD APPLY TO BOTH THE?
RETAIL SALES HI AND THE THINGS
THAT ARE OFFICIALLY CALLED NON
RETAIL CELLS BUT ARE STILL.
SOLD ON TO CONSUMERS WILL
CERTAINLY TAKE ON CAR FIND
AMENDMENTS AS WE GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
AND AND PLEASED TO INTRODUCE OUR
TO FOLKS TODAY AS OUR WHICH IS
OUR PRIMARY SUPPORTERS.
SHANE STEPHENS FROM FIRST ON
THAT FUEL AND TO RESET CUT FROM
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE NOW
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
TERESA COOK ON BEHALF OF ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE NOW I'M VERY
PLEASED TO BE SUPPORTING AB --
SEVEN FORTY FIVE AS THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN ELOQUENTLY STATED THERE
ARE TWO MAIN PURPOSES OF THIS
BILL WINE IS THE PARITY AND TAX
TREATMENT BETWEEN BOTH ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE FUELS -- AND
THEN THE SECOND IS RECOGNIZING
THAT FOR THE TIME BEING IN ORDER
TO MEET THE ENVIRONMENT ON%
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS THAT THIS
STATE HAS WE NEED TO TRY TO
REDUCE OR ELIMINATE -- BARRIERS
TO OWNERSHIP -- AND THIS BILL
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO DOING NOT
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- MY
NAME IS DOCTOR SHANE STEPHENS ON
ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF FIRST ON
THE FUEL -- WERE COMPANY FOUNDED
AND BASED IN IRVINE CALIFORNIA.
AND WE RETAIL HYDROGEN TO KERR'S
BOOKS -- THE THE THING WE DO --
SO TODAY WE DO PAY A SALES AND
USE TAX OUR CONSUMERS DO -- AT
THE PUMP -- BECAUSE OF OLD CODE --
YOU KNOW IT'S ODD FOR A
TRANSPORTATION FUEL TO BE
TREATED THIS WAY BUT THAT'S THE
THE OLD CODE THE WAIT IS.
A PLUG IN ELECTRIC ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES DO NOT PAY ANY KIND OF
NOT TAX WHEN THEY CHARGE UP.
BECAUSE OF THAT SB ONE WAS
INTRODUCED AND PASSED LAST YEAR --
SO THAT ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
WOULD PAY A REGISTRATION FEE --
TO MAKE UP FOR WHAT THEY'RE NOT
PAYING AT THE PUMP -- HOWEVER
FUEL CELL CARS GOT LUMPED INTO
THAT CATEGORY.
TOO SO NOW WE HAVE THE JOY OF
PAYING ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
FENCE WE PAY AT THE PUMP.
AND WE PAY THIS REGISTRATION FEE.
SO I THINK THE PARITY ARGUMENT
IS A IS A VERY STRONG -- ONE AND
WE WOULD LIKE.
TO GET TREATED IN THE SAME
CATEGORY AS THE PLUGIN ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND NOT HAVE A
CONSUMERS ALSO BEING.
HIT WITH TAXES AT THE PUMP --
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO
MENTION ABOUT THIS BILL IS THAT --
WE DID VOLUNTARILY INTRODUCE --
SUNSET DATE -- KNOWING THAT
DAVID RUFFIN MAKE US DO SO
ANYWAY -- BUT THE THE IDEA
BEHIND THAT WAS -- YOU KNOW TO
GET.
LUMPED INTO THIS KIND OF SB ONE
CATEGORIZATION OF JOBS FOR NOW.
BUT WE THINK IN FOUR YEARS ONCE --
WE'VE GROWN TO A SLIGHTLY LARGER
LEVEL WE HELP.
OUT WE COULD HAVE A MORE
MEANINGFUL DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
HOW SHOULD HYDROGEN BE TREATED
RIGHT SHOULD IT BE -- TAX MORE
LIKE GASOLINE SHOULD BE THAT
CONTINUE TO BE A REGISTRATION
FEE OR YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE EVEN
TALKING ABOUT MAYBE A VMT TAX.
AND A WHOLE KIND OF OVERALL OF
THE CODE SO -- WE HOPE THAT
COINCIDES WITH -- ARE SOME SAID
THEY COINCIDES WITH A BIGGER
DISCUSSION WE CAN HAVE ABOUT
THAT -- AND FINALLY I JUST WANNA
TALK ABOUT THE REALITY OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND -- TODAY
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE ABOUT
SEVEN THOUSAND FUEL CELL CARS ON
THE ROAD -- THAT'S BEEN
OCCURRING OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS -- IT'S AN EXCITING START --
BUT THAT'S A VERY SMALL VOLUME
OF CARS -- SOME FUEL IS A
VOLUMES GAME RIGHT WHEN WE GET
TO MORE SIGNIFICANT VOLUMES THE
ECONOMICS WORK VERY WELL WE CAN
BE COMPETITIVE.
TODAY IS VERY HARD TO BE
COMPETITIVE.
AND SO OUR PRICES ARE HIGHER AT
THE PUMP THAN WHAT WE WOULD LIKE
AND WHERE THEY NEED TO BE.
BECAUSE OF THAT AUTO MAKERS HAVE
BEEN PAYING FOR SOME OF THE FUEL --
THIS IS NUMBER ONE DISCOURAGING
TO AUTO MAKERS YOU KNOW THIS IS
NOT A GAME THAT THEY CAN BE IN
LONG TERM TO PAY FOR THE FUEL.
NUMBER TWO THE OTHER THING THAT
STARTED HAPPENING IS -- AFTER
THREE YEARS OF SALES A LOT OF
THESE CARS HAVE BEEN EITHER
COMING OFF LEASE AND HAVE TO GO
INTO THE SECOND HAND MARKET.
OR LEAVE FOR THOSE WHO BOUGHT
AND OWNED THE CAR THE THREE
YEARS OF FREE FUEL PAID BY
AUTOMAKERS HAS TIMED UP.
SO NOW CONSUMERS ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING HIT BY THIS DIRECTLY --
AND IT'S GOING TO I THINK
BECAUSE A GROWING PROBLEM OF
USED FUEL CELL CARS SITTING ON
THE LOT RATHER THAN BEING PUT
INTO THEIR THEIR SECOND SECOND
LIFE AND I THINK FOR FOR MANY
COMMUNITIES AS CHAIRWOMAN UPPER
POINTED OUT.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT --
THAT USED CAR MARKET SO THAT
CONSUMERS CAN GET INTO THE
SERVICE.
AND DOT RIGHT NOW THE PRICE OF
FUEL AT THE PUMP IS CAUSING A
PROBLEM SO SO IN ADDITION TO THE
PERRY ARGUMENT THIS WILL JUST.
HELP US AT THIS POINT WE'RE A
SMALL YOU KNOW NON PROFITABLE
COMPANY AND INDUSTRY -- GET TO A
FASTER WHERE WE CAN COMPETE WITH
MORE CONVENTIONAL FUELS THANK
YOU.
ADDITIONAL IN THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
ISRAEL SALAS WITH SO CAL GAS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SOME OF THE CARBON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION I WON'T BELABOR MY
EARLIER POINTS BUT LOOK FORWARD
TO COMMUNICATING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AS WELL AS THE
CHAIR IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN A
SORT OF LARGER CONVERSATION ON
THIS BETWEEN NOW AND A POTENTIAL
THOáT.
THANK YOU.
DARKER OF COURSE -- SO I DON'T
HIDE WE'VE HAD THIS DISCUSSION.
I CAN IMAGINE.
WE'VE HAD THIS DISCUSSION BEFORE
THE THE DIFFICULTY IS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE OWNING
HYGIENE VEHICLE.
OUR WELL THE BASICALLY GETTING
THEM FOR FREE.
AND AND THERE ARE CERTAINLY FOR
BOTH THE HONDA AND TOYOTA YOU
GET THIS FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
BACK AT THE VERY BEGINNING.
AND THEN THEY PAY FOR YOUR FUEL
FURTHER I'VE BEEN TOLD BY THE
HONDA PEOPLE THAT WHEN THE THREE
YEARS IS UP THEY WANT THE CAR
BACK.
THEY DON'T WANT IT ON A USED CAR
LOT BECAUSE THEY SAY THE
TECHNOLOGY WILL HAVE CHANGED.
SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO KNOW IS ARE
THERE ANY PEOPLE OUT THERE OF
THE SEVEN THOUSAND VEHICLES
WOULD ACTUALLY BENEFIT FROM THIS.
THE REASON THAT.
THE AUTOMAKERS ARE DOING THIS
SUBSIDIZING THE FUEL IS NOT ONLY
BECAUSE THE FUEL COST BUT THESE
ARE WERE BETA TESTERS.
I HAD TO HAVE THE WHOLE FUEL.
TANK REPLACED A FEW MONTHS INTO
MY OWNERSHIP BECAUSE IT STOPPED
WORKING.
AND RIGHT NOW IT'S GONE FROM
GETTING.
THREE HUNDRED MILES ON A FAILED
TO GETTING TO FIFTY SO I'M GOING
TO TAKE IT IN AGAIN TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED THE WERE BETA
TESTERS.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING AT LEAST
FROM HONDA IS THEY DON'T EVEN
WANT THEM ON THE ROAD ONCE THE
LEASE IS UP.
SO THIS THEN BECOMES MORE OF A
REWARD THAN INCENTIVE NOW IF YOU
CAN SHOW ME THERE'S GONNA BE
LOTS OF PEOPLE ON THE ROAD.
AND THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN RIGHT
NOW WE PAY THE EQUIVALENT OF
EIGHT DOLLARS A GALLON -- THAT
IF YOU REDUCE THAT.
TO SEVEN TWENTY THAT THAT'LL
MAKE A DIFFERENCE I DON'T THINK
SO BUT MY CONCERN IS THIS REALLY
WILD.
PROMOTE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
PROMOTE -- AND ALREADY THE STATE
WITH A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
REBATE IS AND A STICKER IF YOU
MAKE LESS THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND A YEAR.
IS ALREADY PROMOTING THIS IN A
MAJOR WAY AND I'M AGAIN I JUST
THINK THIS WILL BE A BREAK FOR
HONDA AND TOYOTA -- BUT YOU KNOW
THEY'RE NOT DOING THIS BECAUSE
YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE MONEY ON IT
THEY'RE DOING IT BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE IN THE TECHNOLOGY AND
THEY KNOW WERE BETA TESTERS.
AND THEY'RE TREATING THIS VERY
NICELY.
I WOULD I WOULD CERTAINLY AGREE
THAT THESE ARE YOU THESE ARE NAY
SENT TECHNOLOGIES AND I THINK
THAT.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I THINK AS
POLICY MAKERS.
YOU I'D LIKE TO SEE AS IT I
THINK WE CAN'T -- IT WE'VE GOT
WE'VE ALWAYS GOT KIND OF TWO
TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL AS POLICY
MAKERS IS EITHER REGULATIONS OR
INTENT VISITATION THAT'S
DESIGNED TO SPARK INNOVATION
ENTERED HER CHANGE BEHAVIOR AND
I'M.
AT A TAKE ON BOARD THAT PERHAPS
THERE'S ALREADY A LOT OF
INCENTIVE IS ATION HAPPENING FOR
THE ADOPTION OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
SO WE'LL LOOK AT THAT AND WE
ALSO GET BACK AT YOU.
AND IN TERMS OF OF THE PEOPLE
THAT WOULD IN FACT.
BENEFIT FROM THE SHIFT THANK YOU
THAT BE HELPFUL.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I'M SUPER AS I SAID THE PURPOSE
OF THIS SPELL IS TO INCENTIVIZE
THE ADOPTION IS YOUR MISSION
VEHICLES AS PART OF OUR STRATEGY
TO ACHIEVE CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
GOALS.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR COMMENTS
AND INPUT AS WE WORK THROUGH
THIS WILL CERTAINLY TAKE THAT ON
BOARD AND DIE.
THANK YOU ALSO TO MY GUESTS FOR
BEING HERE.
THINGS LIKE LAST FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WE MOVE THIS FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB
.
EIGHT FIFTY SIX THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I DO NOT HAVE ZERO
EMISSIONS BILL HERE.
I DO HOWEVER HAVE AB EIGHT FIFTY
SIX THAT WILL PROVIDE A PERSONAL
INCOME TAX CREDIT FOR SENIOR AND
DISABLED HOME CARE SERVICES OF
UP TO FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AB A FIFTY SIX WOULD EASE THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON SENIORS WHO
WANT TO STAY IN OUR HOMES BUT
NEED HELP WITH THEIR DAILY TASKS.
AS THE COST OF SENIOR CARE
CONTINUES TO RISE ONE THE MOST
AFFORDABLE AND EFFECTIVE OPTIONS
FOR SENIORS WHO WISH TO STAY IN
THEIR HOME.
IS HOME CARE HOME CARE SERVICES
ARE PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE IN
PROVIDING SENIORS MORE
AFFORDABLE CARE OPTION IN
NURSING HOMES AND ARE SUBJECT TO
LICENSING AND REGULATION BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AB EIGHT FIFTY SIX WILL CREATE A
TAX CREDIT FOR THOSE WHO
STRUGGLE TO AFFORD CARE.
BUT MAKE TOO MUCH TO QUALIFY FOR
STATE FUNDED IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES THE BILL PROVIDES A
PRACTICAL SOLUTION TO HELP
SENIORS ACCOMPLISH EVERYDAY
ACTIVITIES.
WITHOUT THE EXPENSE OF A NURSING
HOME OR HOSPITAL STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT HOME CARE REDUCES
HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS AND
READMISSIONS KEEPING DOWN THE
COST TO GOVERNMENT FUNDED HEALTH
CARE INCLUDING MEDICARE.
AND MEDICAID.
WITH PEOPLE SEVENTY FIVE AND
OLDER BECOMING THE FASTEST
GROWING AGE GROUP BY TWENTY
TWENTY AND NINE OUT OF TEN
AMERICANS AGE SIXTY FIVE AND
OLDER WANTING TO STAY IN THEIR
HOMES AS LONG AS POSSIBLE.
THIS BILL IS CRUCIAL TO
EMPOWERING SENIORS TO LIVE THOSE
ACTIVE LIVES TO REMAIN CONNECTED
WITH THEIR FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
THANK YOU -- WITH ME IN SUPPORT
OUR IGNACIO CEPEDA'S FROM BRIGHT
STAR CARE AND KATHY HER FELT
WITH HOME CARE ASSISTANCE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ARE MAKING
US ASSISTANCE ON THE OWNER AND
OPERATOR OF PRICE START CARE
HAVE BEEN FOR ELEVEN YEARS HERE
IN THE SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY
PROVIDING HOME CARE.
AND I'M SURE YOU OFFER FROM HERE
WITH IT AND YOU MAY HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS OR PEOPLE YOU KNOW THAT
ARE RECEIVING CARE -- WHEN
PEOPLE DON'T RECEIVE CARE IN THE
HOME THAT THEY NEED -- THEY
DON'T HAVE FAMILY TO SUPPORT
THEM -- INEVITABLY ARE THEY PUT
THEMSELVES IN DANGER SO THERE'S
NEGLECT NEGLECT FOR THEIR OWN
CARE THE END UP -- THEIR
NUTRITION SUFFERS THEIR SAFETY
SUFFERS THEIR ACTIVITY LEVEL
STAFFERS WHEN ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON THINGS THAT HAPPENS IS
THERE ARE THERE ARE AVOIDABLE
FALLS THAT HE NEVER.
INEVITABLY TURN TO E. R. VISITS
HOSPITAL STAYS.
A NURSING HOME -- THIS IT
SOMETIMES NURSING HOME STAYS SO
THAT'S A ISSUE THE QUESTION IS
WHY DON'T PEOPLE HAVE MORE CARE
AND IT'S AN ISSUE OF
AFFORDABILITY SO THAT'S WHAT I
THINK HIS BILL IS ABOUT -- THE
PEOPLE IN THE LOW END OF THE
SPECTRUM HAVE SOME PUBLIC
SUPPORT THROUGH HSS PROGRAM.
PEOPLE ARE THE HIGH END OF THE
SPECTRUM HAVE DISCRETIONARY
INCOME.
OR NICE FAT LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE POLICIES TO PAY FOR IT
BUT PEOPLE ARE IN THE LOWER.
LOWER MIDDLE INCOME RANGE CANNOT
AFFORD ENOUGH CARE AND IN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY THIS IS
GETTING MORE AND MORE EXPENSIVE
OVER THE LAST. THREE FOUR YEARS
WITH THE ADVENT OF PAID SICK
LEAVE OVER TIME.
THEY REDUCTION OF SLEEPOVER --
EXCEPTIONS -- AN EXAMPLE IS IT
WOULD USED TO BE THE LIVING CARE
WHEN SOMEBODY WAS TAKEN CARE FOR
SOMEBODY TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
A DAY HAS GONE DOWN BY 90%. 90%
SO IT IS CERTAINLY AN
AFFORDABILITY ISSUE NOW THAT'S
EXPENSIVE AND IF THEY CARE
SPECTRUM.
IN THE LOW AND THE SCARE
SPECTRUM I CAN TELL YOU WITH
MINIMUM WAGE THE CARE GIVERS IN
THIS INDUSTRY MAKE THEIR ABOVE
MINIMUM WAGE AT LEAST TO MY
COMPANY BUT NOT FAR.
SO MINIMUM WAGE GOES UP CARE
GOES UP AND HIS HIS LAST YEAR
WITH INCREASED TO TWELVE OH CARE
WHEN UP AND THAT'S MORE
INCREASING IN THE COST OF CARE.
HAS CREATED A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER OF HOURS
THAT PEOPLE CAN AFFORD.
SO IS DEFINITELY THERE'S A ONE
TO ONE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN EVEN
SMALL CHANGES IN THE COST OF
CARE.
HOW MUCH CARE PEOPLE RECEIVE?
SO I BELIEVE THAT THIS -- A TAX
CREDIT CAN BE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HELPS AND ACTUALLY THIS
REDUCTION OF OURS IS USUALLY AND
THE PEOPLE WITH MORE LIMITED
INCOME.
THE ONES ARE GETTING FOR SIX
HOURS OR EIGHT HOURS NOW THEY
DIVIDED DOWN INTO TWO FOUR SO
FOR HOURS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD IT.
SO I THINK THIS TAX CREDIT COULD
CERTAINLY SWEET IT HIT A SWEET
SPOT IN.
ALLOWING MORE PEOPLE TO READ
REMAIN -- PROVIDING CARE FOR THE
LOVE ONCE IN THEIR HOME.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M GOING TO BE
REALLY BOLD AND SAY THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME I'VE EVER.
TESTIFYING FROM COMMITTEE SO.
BEAR WITH ME THANK YOU -- MY
NAME IS KATHY HER FELT MY OWN
HOME CARE ASSISTANCE HERE ANY
SACRAMENTO -- I SPENT THIRTY
YEARS IN IT BEFORE I GOT INTO
THIS BUSINESS AND THE REASON WHY
I GOT INTO THIS BUSINESS WAS
BECAUSE I SAW THE NEED. FOR CARE
AND OF THE OF THE RAISING THE
BAR FOR CARE IN IN CALIFORNIA
HERE -- ONE OF THE THINGS I
THINK OF I REALLY WANT TO POINT
OUT TO YOU WITH REGARD TO THIS
BILL IS.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE SERIOUS
CONSTRAINTS IN JUST PROVIDING
CARE IN GENERAL.
AND WHAT THAT ONE THE REASONS
WHY I GOT INTO THIS BUSINESS IS
BECAUSE WHEN I WAS WORKING FOR
COMPANIES THAT WERE STARTED BY
INTEL KAREN EVASIONS WAS A COME
AS WORKING FOR IS THERE WERE
STATS THAT SHOW DO WILL NOT BE
ENOUGH BRICKS AND MORTAR PLACES
FOR PEOPLE TO GO.
WE HAVE NOT KEPT UP WITH THE
DEMAND.
OVER BETWEEN NOW AND TWO
THOUSAND THIRTY WILL APLEY AGE
OUT.
THERE WILL NOT BE PLACES TO GO
SO WHAT DOES THAT DO IT AND I
ALSO READ AN ARTICLE JUST TODAY
JUST IN PREPARING FOR THIS.
IS THAT OF THE NEAR TIMES POSTED
ON MARCH FOURTH THAT IS STATED
DUE TO CORPORATE BUYOUTS AND
FINANCIAL RUIN MANY SENIOR CARE
FACILITIES HAVE GONE OUT OF
BUSINESS LEAVING SENIORS TO AGE
IN THEIR OWN HOMES.
SO FRANKLY THE OPTION IS THERE
GOING TO HAVE TO STAY IN THEIR
HOME.
BECAUSE FIRST FOR THE CAN'T
AFFORD IT SECONDLY THERE'S NOT
GONNA BE ANY OTHER OPTIONS.
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO FOR THESE
GUYS WELL.
STAYING AT HOME MIGHT BE A GOOD
OPTION -- AND MOST OF MY CLIENTS
TO WANT TO STAY AT HOME.
UT THE RESOURCES WILL NOT KEEP
PACE WITH THE DEMAND.
THERE'S JUST NOT GONNA BE ENOUGH
CARE PEOPLE TO GO AROUND
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW HERE IN EAST
EARING YOU SACRAMENTO.
I'M RUNNING INTO CONSTRAINTS
BECAUSE AMAZON'S HIRING MY
PEOPLE AWAY
STARBUCKS.
THEY'RE ALL PAYING HIGHER
MINIMUM WAGE IN THE LABOR FORCE
IS SO STRONG RIGHT NOW THE OTHER
FOR DIFFERENT OPTIONS AND SO.
EVER CONSTRAINTS ARE REALLY.
AUG CONSTRAINED WHAT A SECOND TO
DO THAT'S GOING TO MAKE ME PAY
THEM MORE.
WHICH MEANS I'M GONNA HAVE TO
CHARGE MY CLIENTS MORE.
OKAY SO TO OUR POINT HERE IS
THAT CARE IS ONLY GOING TO GET
MORE EXPENSIVE.
SO HOW CAN WE CREATE SOME SORT
OF SAFETY NET FOR OUR CLIENTS
AND OUR CONSTITUENTS TO MAKE
SURE THE CARE IN THE HOME WHICH
FOR HOPE WILL PROBABLY BE THE
ONLY OPTION THEY HAVE.
MORE AFFORDABLE.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE
HOPEFULLY IT'LL EASE SOME OF THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT THAT IS GOING
TO HAPPEN TO OUR SENIORS HERE IN
THE MARKET -- IT JUST IT JUST
MAKES SENSE WE WE ARE RUNNING
INTO.
THE TRAIN'S LEFT THE STATION AND
WE'RE RUNNING INTO A BRICK WALL
UNLESS WE DO SOME SORT OF THING
AROUND KEEPING OUR KEY OUR
SENIORS SAFE.
AT HOME.
THANK YOU.
THINK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON RATE NEBRASKA
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH SERVICES AT
HOME IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
OPPOSE YOUR BILLS CAR.
SHE HAD TO TODAY THAT SHE WAS IN
BETWEEN I'M TRYING REAL HARD
SADLY WE'RE NOT THE ANALYSIS BUT
WE DO IN FACT POSE THIS BILL AND
SOME CORPORATE ON BEHALF OF C.
T. R. A..
BUT WE DO ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
THE MERIT ON THIS ISSUE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S ATTENDS --
COMPARED TO SOME OTHER BILLS
THAT HAVE BEEN BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF ATTEMPTING
TO NARROW BUT ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT USING THE
GENERAL FUND IN THIS WAY -- I
BILLION DOLLAR COST FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS TO FUND THIS -- PROGRAM
ABOUT A BILLION AND A HALF WHICH
WOULD COME DIRECTLY FROM KEY
THROUGH FOURTEEN EDUCATION -- WE
FEEL STRONGLY THAT A EXPANSION
OF OUR SHORING UP OF AYE HSS OR
SOME OTHER TYPE OF GRANT PROGRAM
THAT WOULD DIRECTLY ASSIST
INDIVIDUALS.
IN PROCURING SUPPORTING THESE
TYPE OF SERVICES WOULD BE BEST
IN MEETING THIS NEED -- BUT DO
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEE THAT SEEING NONE.
SOME OF OUR PRO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU I JUST -- AS
WE SAID THIS BILL IS A SIGN FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T QUALIFY FOR
AGES SAYS JUST A LITTLE ABOUT IT.
AND WE FEEL COUPLE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GOES A LONG WAY IF THESE
PEOPLE HAVE TO GO INTO SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES ARE GOING
MEDI CAL IT'S GOING TO BE AT THE
BIGGER EXPENSE FOR THE STATE.
AND I JUST ASK FOR SUPPORT WHEN
IT COMES FOR VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK.
WE ARE ADJOURNED.
A GOOD JOB. FOR THREE YEARS
[inaudible]
LAWLER